missed you okay challenges strip to our
underwear get in the snow first wanted
to get up walks around the block naked
let's do it you went all right let's go
baby come on Jordan I'm sorry but a
kidney transplant is the only solution
you're all I've got
it's nearly 200,000 I'd go back to what
I was doing I don't want you to do that
for me
all I'm trying to do is protect you you
have come back I knew it
you look tense start carrying golf balls
packed with drugs
you steal truck you bring it to me
but then you make your money is it
dangerous
what kind of god sell them
I wonder who this foolish man could
possibly be I misjudged you hello there
friend
I believe I have something you want
leave her out of this when people tried
to steal for me
an innocent characters died violent and
meaningless deaths Oh Juliet
I'm coming to get you to hit
from little piggy run run run hey stay
cool man all this trouble all this pain
everything I have they're gonna figure
out what I've done did you access an
unauthorized throw around the government
knows that we have these documents now